today we're going to talk about the best
foods to clean out your liver your liver
is not
necessarily dirty okay it doesn't
accumulate toxins in fact its main
function is to detoxify toxins and
poisons and chemicals but it's not a
storage facility for
poisons and chemicals unless you have a
fatty liver because these toxins are
stored in your fat cells now when your
liver gets inflamed it heals with scar
tissue
and you can develop cirrhosis and you
can lose function and create all sorts
of issues but
the liver itself is not a reservoir for
toxins so i want to shift my talk into
the best foods to
reestablish
the full function of your liver to get
your liver able to detoxify
at the highest level and you can totally
do this with foods so we're going to
cover all those but i want to first talk
about the different functions of the
liver okay it has the ability to
detoxify
it makes bile
bile is a detergent to help you break
down fats and extract certain nutrients
from fat your liver is a main producer
of hormones that's right
one being igf-1 insulin-like growth
factor number one now what is that that
is a very similar hormone to growth
hormone growth hormone is made by your
pituitary gland it's sent to the liver
it works through the liver and you can
kind of consider igf number one as an
extension of growth hormone
it performs very similar functions so it
has everything to do with helping you
burn fat
it's a anabolic hormone so it helps you
build muscle it has everything to do
with building proteins and it also can
help tap into your fat reserves and your
stored sugar reserves for fuel now your
liver also makes steroid hormones okay
like estrogen progesterone
testosterone vitamin d3 which by the way
acts like a hormone in the body in fact
it probably is a hormone but we
classified it as a vitamin and the other
sex hormone is cortisol the main
anti-inflammatory hormone in the body
the main hormone that helps you adapt to
stress so without cortisol your body
can't adapt to stress and you're going
to get really stressed out in fact 80
percent of the cortisol floating through
your bloodstream originates from your
liver so all these steroid hormones
come from
this one thing
cholesterol
and so the liver is part of the building
block of not just cholesterol but a real
key part in the creation of those
hormones and what's interesting is that
people take certain drugs to block
cholesterol like statins
well guess what's going to happen to
these hormones you're not going to be
able to make them efficiently you're
going to have all sorts of issues and
your liver makes a good portion of the
cholesterol in your body and take a
while guess
what material it makes cholesterol from
if you guess dietary sugars you are
correct so cholesterol is made from
carbs and cholesterol also makes certain
proteins
certain proteins that transport things
in the body like cholesterol like
estrogen like testosterone
different hormones because these
hormones made from cholesterol can't
travel that well through the blood your
liver packages them in protein so they
can be transported so your liver has a
post office function in that it is able
to package certain things and send them
throughout the body now these proteins
just don't transport certain things they
also
buffer or regulate certain hormones
so if there's too much estrogen for
example or too much cortisol
your liver will buffer that with these
proteins to make sure that things are in
balance all right so those are just some
of the many functions of the liver your
liver actually has 500 different
functions now before i get to the food i
just want to briefly mention the
different symptoms that occur when you
have damage to the liver
one would be itchiness in the body
another one would be that your skin in
the whites of the eyes turn yellow it's
called jaundice the next one is lethargy
and then you have achy joints
so many people who are stiff and have
inflammation in the joints
really have a
liver problem
feeling nauseous is a big symptom of the
liver having a lowered cognitive
function could be liver related and if
you have gallstones there's definitely a
problem with the liver simply because
the liver makes bile and it's a
deficiency of bile and a high level of
cholesterol
that makes you end up with gallstones
all right so now let's dive into the
best foods for your liver okay number
one
cruciferous vegetables okay talking
about kale broccoli brussels sprouts
radish
arugula
wasabi
mustard mustard greens they are all
cruciferous vegetables they are very
high in a natural phytonutrient called
sulforaphane and sulforaphane helps to
detoxify the liver it helps the liver to
get rid of inflammation and inflammation
leads to insulin resistance it leads to
high insulin it leads to diabetes and it
can even lead to cancer so sulfurophane
is a really important
liver protective compound and it can
also help if there's fat in the liver
and with enough sulforaphane
let's say for example if you drank too
much coffee
sulforaphane helps to quickly detoxify
things like caffeine
drugs chemicals and even poisons eating
cruciferous vegetables with sulforaphane
can even enhance the liver to the point
of having an enhanced
function of the liver even two weeks
after where you stopped eating
cruciferous vegetables so some of the
effects from eating cruciferous
vegetables
extend into the future even if you don't
eat them that's pretty cool now if you
consume cruciferous sprouts okay
you get a major enhancement in
sulforaphane especially when we're
talking about broccoli sprouts radish
sprouts and even mustard seed sprouts so
sprouting is a very very smart thing to
do because all you need is just a little
bit of those sprouts on your salad to
create a huge effect you see one of the
key enzymes to
activate sulforaphane is destroyed with
heat so if you overcook broccoli or
especially
cauliflower you're not going to be able
to get this full magnitude of
sulfurophane
unless you at the same time add a little
sprouts to your salad or a little bit of
raw cruciferous or
if you added a little bit of mustard to
your meal because mustard has a lot of
that enzyme because it's a cruciferous
that will help activate sulforaphane in
the food that is cooked so this is just
another reason why when you have a salad
um you want to add different things to
it like
sprouts and there's many other
phytonutrients in cruciferous vegetables
that support the liver function which
also have a lot to do with decreasing um
complications from diabetes and free
radical damage and improving sensitivity
to insulin and improving insulin
resistance and just supporting your
blood sugars personally i consume a lot
of arugula in my salads so that is just
loaded with those enzymes to activate
sulforaphane i also do a lot of raw
cabbage like coleslaw for example and
sauerkraut which is just loaded with the
enzymes to activate sulforaphane so out
of all the things you can eat
cruciferous is at the top of the list
now the number two item is garlic now
garlic is something that is loaded with
sulfur and sulfur is a wonderful thing
to detoxify the liver and also act as a
natural antibiotic so it's very very
anti-bacterial anti-fungal
anti-viral
and garlic is really good for stripping
off fat from your liver
and garlic also has a lot of vitamin b1
as well i mean garlic is just one of
those superfoods it's anti-inflammatory
it's a very powerful antioxidant and it
has huge anti-cancer properties all
right the next one for the liver is
turmeric okay now the active
phytonutrient in turmeric is curcumin
curcumin is just a powerhouse in
reducing inflammation there is someone
recently who
had
lifelong headaches okay and they had to
take copious amounts of
tylenol for years and years and years
and their liver has been going downhill
and so one of the key things that she
did is started taking turmeric on a
daily basis and so not only did her
headaches go away but now going in the
future not having to take tylenol her
liver is going to do much much better
now one thing i want to say about the
liver is that the liver is rugged it's
tough it can bounce back
unless it's completely destroyed it only
needs a little bit of itself to function
and a lot of people have destroyed a
good portion of the livers and they're
able to
exist and survive which is quite amazing
but out of all the organs the liver is
the most
robust it can take a beating and it can
bounce back now turmeric can also
detoxify heavy metals like lead
mercury
cadmium and even arsenic turmeric helps
to repair and regenerate liver function
tumeric helps stabilize the mitochondria
which is why it's very anti-cancer
because the origin of cancer happens
with damaged mitochondria
tumeric is very heavily studied
especially in its ability to
decrease fat on your liver so if you
combine a ketogenic diet low carb with
intermittent fasting and turmeric and
some of these other
compounds you're going to be in really
good shape as far as having a healthy
liver now the next one on the list is
beets
beets have always been known to help
detox the liver they can help reduce
liver enzymes if the liver enzymes are
high they can help reduce them
the phytonutrients in the pigments and
beets can help activate the release of
bile salts and that can help
decrease the fat in your liver but beets
are hepatoprotective which means they
protect the liver cells and they can
significantly reduce inflammation in the
liver and if they can reduce
inflammation in liver they can slow down
the process of fibrosis and scar tissue
and cirrhosis now a question that people
might have is what about beets
and being keto friendly is it going to
spike my blood sugars well if you don't
juice beets and you have them steamed
there is some carbohydrates in there but
if you add the fiber in there that will
buffer the insulin response and so in a
half a cup of beets you're looking at
about only 6.7 grams of carbs
not terribly high now the next food i
want to talk about is mushrooms now
what's so important about mushrooms with
the liver well mushrooms are the food
that has some of the highest amount of
glutathione
and glutathione is the main antioxidant
for the liver especially if you do
turkey tail mushroom and oyster
mushrooms and other mushrooms as well
mushrooms are hepatoprotective that
means they protect the cells of the
liver all right now we get to avocados
avocados
are a great thing to consume to help
repair and stabilize the liver avocados
too are high in glutathione that support
the liver and but the main thing about
avocados is all you have to do is
consume
one avocado a week to see significant
improvements in your liver function
avocados are very very anti-inflammatory
and
inflammation in the liver leads to so
many issues including hepatitis
including fatty liver as well as
cirrhosis so anything that can lower
inflammation would be very good for the
liver and the last thing i'm going to
recommend for the liver is extra virgin
olive oil just a very small amount in
fact just one little teaspoon in your
salad dressing can create significant
improvements in liver enzymes extra
virgin olive oil decreases fat on your
liver it improves insulin sensitivity it
reduces insulin resistance
and it's a very powerful
anti-inflammatory so there you have it
the best foods to help support a healthy
liver and if you haven't seen some of my
other videos on the liver i created a
playlist for you right here
check it out